you know i heckled him did you i had to
uh
rickles it was the end of his show and
he's just doing question answering and i
was just way in the back and
and i wasn't going to get to meet him
and i had to have an interaction with
him yeah
so i just was in the back and as he was
talking making everybody laugh i just
went donny
[Laughter]
he didn't say anything i waited like
another five minutes he kept doing jokes
and then i just then i went
dawning he just looked and he goes yeah
i know my name
and then and then my buddy like you hit
me he's like okay that was it that's all
i needed that was enough
yeah people in front of me were mad at
me and [ __ ] and then afterwards i was
like well i just really did what
yeah of course yeah i just did that
right so everybody's like
we can't bring up sinatra you know
because you know rickles and sinatra are
pretty close
so
not
he goes yeah available saw him last week
it was a lot of this
spit coming out of his mouth and then he
goes
because it was a lot of fun it was it
was a lot of me two inches from his face
going i'm not
barbara
of don reckles and at the end of the day
i got rapped and i'm leaving the show
and i went up to him i go mr rickles
it's an honor to meet you i'm kevin
farley and boy i tell you i'm just you
know kind of new to show business and
just
being around you and you know it was
just an honor of my life
and he goes
you're very dressed up tonight that's
right yeah i heard you were talking
about how rickles
what he said about what he saw on the
left
you guys were here together one night
and rickles
saw spotted you and there was a bunch of
people around and brickles yelled
hey let's take up a collection and buy
adam a suit that's right that's right
man is this what you got yeah yeah this
is the respect for the man
now he he was just the greatest guy i
do i i mean you really got to be tight
with him i i
had like hit and run and i mean i
worshiped the guy too because my father
worshipped him
oh yeah you know like that's how it goes
your dad loves somebody you love so much
so anyways i i was at dinner with steve
buscemi
this is like 25 years ago or something
we were sitting
at dantanas and eating and then rickles
came over to us and we were like oh my
god this is this is happening right now
and he says to buchemi something like uh
maybe 23 whatever years ago he says
something about
i saw your movie uh mr pink
more like mr stink or something like
that and boucher
was like and then he laughs and he goes
maybe get some braces
[Applause]
i think it was happy gilmore or
something he goes so i had to begin one
watch the whole thing wow
amazing how no talent can get you a move
how are you well i'm glad your ankle is
better because i know you hurt your
ankle
yeah i pulled my uh i pulled my tendon
that's bad right no it's good
[Laughter]
you like wrinkles right now did you play
sports
or you was an athlete you like rickles
right i love wrinkles yeah i was
uh i did a movie with rickles right
uh-huh so uh so it's so awesome dirty
work right dirty work yeah
so it's so awesome i like it so it's so
awesome
and uh and uh so he couldn't remember
remember
he couldn't remember any lines you know
so uh so i'd go like i
wrote write something i thought sounded
like wriggles like i go uh hey uh uh
um say don say this to artie lang you
know say
uh uh uh baskin robbins called me today
and they're down to three flavors so uh
so then he goes he goes look at you he
goes baskins and johnson called me
he goes you know what they told me they
told me you ate
all their ice cream all the right tubs
and tubs of ice cream
and now they don't it's like 45 minutes
so uh
so but there's the violence man you
don't give don wrinkles lines
man let him come up with this you gotta
let him go yeah that's right but uh
reckless man he's he's the real he's the
best
yeah he's the funniest guy and uh so
that week sinatra was on his deathbed
frank sinatra frank sinatra rickles you
know close friend
you know so at lunch i was like people
were like should we mention sinatra i
don't think we should mention the bum
amount you know
but then i said i i want to ask him you
know so i said hey frank like
i mean hey don have you uh have you
talked to frank lately you know
and he goes yeah i saw him last week
there was a lot of this
[Applause]
this guy died four days later and then i
said uh i said oh and he goes yeah
because it's a lot of me with my uh with
my head
two inches from frank's face going i'm
not
barbara
well frank wouldn't want it in any other
way that's very true
funniest fan encounter funniest fan
probably uh rickles rickles my
girlfriend is
uh quite a bit younger than me you know
the drill and uh
we were at a restaurant and she's young
but she's uh
you know she's she's growing i mean
she's you know she's blossoming this is
her summer
and uh rickles walks up to the table and
uh
looks at her and looks at me and goes
12.
she's 12. and then he says have you ever
you've been kidnapped darling have you
been kidnapped blink if you've been
kidnapped
that was a that was a funny encounter it
killed the sex because you know don hit
on her and left barbara in the lobby
but he's my hero you became friendly
with my friend our mutual friend don
rickles
uh before he passed away when is the
last time you saw don
the the last time i saw him was it that
uh that uh
the thing in new york you know i see the
big show yeah yeah and did don
ever like get a hold of you and insult
you did he i mean i know you guys spoke
and stuff but did he let you have it
no well see if
all i wanted was to be razzed by don
rickles right yeah
i was i've been waiting for years and
got nothing he was always so sweet
and that the new york thing uh where we
were out to
it was like a roast or something yeah it
was a tribute yeah right
so i ran backstage to go see don before
he
was coming out i run back real quick
and uh he's sitting in a chair and i
said i said hey don i just want to let
you know
you know i'm here and wish you luck and
everything he goes
he goes john you're here and you're not
late
that's a pretty good don rickles by the
way thanks
listen he would tell he had a kind of a
rotation of stories that he would go
through and if there's somebody new at
the table
he would share those what's your
favorite of all of them maybe even one
that
there were some that he only told with
very small groups is there one that
comes to mind well it'll be the frank
story why don't you tell it you know
he's told that story i think that's
probably the thing people know most
about you know what i'd
but you know maybe this isn't what
you're talking about but i have i knew a
secret because we had the same audio
video guy
and all his passwords were hitler
no actually when we were yeah
okay uh oh yeah a year ago a year ago we
went
that's excellent right that is the
trivia that's really easy to figure out
um we were at the saban theater and he
performed and at that time he couldn't
he couldn't stand
and so he was in the chair and we were
all there and um
he got up one time in the act one time
and it was planned
and it was to goose step he stood yeah
he had to
put the mustache on this is the man he
spent all of his energy to stand up in
the chair
just to walk across the stage just a
goose step and go evolve
i don't know were you ever in a show
where he you know he does exactly
and the the asian person over there and
the african-american person there and
the mexican person
and the lights come up there was no
asian person
well he might have been there yeah